adrien saxo alors à derrière section
vous êtes bien sûr vous êtes contre le
célibat des prêtres on va revenir sur
votre parcours qui est étonnant vous
avez été prêtre pendant deux ans et ça
exactement deux ans et depuis vous avez
quitté la religion pourquoi vous avez
quitté la religion le ciel m'est tombé
sur la tête je suis tombé une femme
amoureuse d'une femme non alors comment
ça s'est passé ça ça ça nous intéresse
célébrer une messe dans une petite
chapelle en semaine ouais une des
paroissiennes qui étaient là a attiré
mon regard mais hélas vous avez enlevé
la salle terminé il est parti en
cacahuète voudrait arriver en deux temps
j'ai pris l'éclair mais sans m'en rendre
compte
ouais si sept mois plus tard c'était
comme un chemin d'amitié pour moi là
j'ai entendu le son les rebonds alors
voir moi ce que j'ai envie de savoir si
vous voulez vous la voyez quand vous l'a
contactée après leur revient et vous
initier ou dollars était allé la voir
discuter un peu à la sortie de la messe
voir si elles voulaient participer à des
activités s'investir un peu plus et
comme elle était très engagé très
investis on avait beaucoup de points
communs on a créé des choses alors elle
a toutes ses copines y ont dit je crois
que le prêtre tout d'agde et le fond
mais non il est prêt à être énorme et
c'est sûr et donc comment vous avez tout
laisser tomber
ouais j'ai tout laissé tomber vous êtes
heureux aujourd'hui aujourd'hui oui je
suis très heureux alors moi la question
que vous pose si c'est comment a réagi
l'église après cette annonce que vous
leur avez annoncé comment voulez vous
vous avez fait quoi
je suis allé trouver affaire déjà j'ai
beaucoup souffert en fait parce que
j'aime rien quand même une certaine
forme de sincérité et la gt entre 2 donc
j'ai dû faire quelques mois deux prêtres
comme ça en allant parler devant les
gens dimanche et en me sentant un
menteur entre alors vous aviez consommer
avant de quitter l'église oui oui
ah oui c'est ça donne quoi vous avez
fait quelques mois 0,5
sacrée belle away vous le souhaitiez
vous étiez dans quel état parce que mine
de rien c'est un sacré mon souffle
ben les états tout ce que j'ai vécu tout
ça j'étais pas loin de penser à assortir
de la vie c'est vrai à wazemmes ont été
vraiment très très très dur n'ai jamais
dit à personne d'ailleurs je le dis ce
soir je sais pas pourquoi mais c'était
vraiment dur quand je suis allé trouver
mon évêque pour lui en parler donc c'est
le responsable de l'église locale
comment il a réagi il m'a dit voilà
on va attendre un peu l'un à oui j'ai
repris rendez vous quelques semaines
plus tard celle et loire il m'a dit
voilà on va attendre un peu enfin il
m'écoutait pas et moi j'étais prêt je
prend une année sabbatique on les
imagine en reprend continue comme ça
c'est ça va se tasser alors avant qu'on
vienne sur votre sur votre histoire
j'ai une question à poser à alexis
leproux vous alexis forcément vous êtes
pour le célibat des prêtres quand vous
auriez réagi vous ben je suis heureux de
pouvoir entendre un homme qui tombe
amoureux est-ce que c'est d'abord un bel
événement j'aurais essayé de
l'accueillir d'abord pour entendre
l'importance de ce qui s'est joué dans
son coeur parce que je pense que c'est
l'essentiel de ce que l'église doit
pouvoir servir ce qui se passe dans le
coeur des gens ça c'est très beau ce que
vous venez ça me semble essentiel à vos
il veut revenir à maintenant la porte
est toujours ouverte mais dans les deux
sens et c'est important
et moi je suis heureux que l'église ne
soit pas une maison dans laquelle on est
enfermé on peut sortir
on peut rentrer il ya beaucoup de choses
vous c'est pas possible
quand vous êtes gamin vous allez à
l'école vous êtes obligés d'aller à
l'école mais après vous faire des études
il faut bosser de c1 mais les glisse
c'est un lieu de gratuité c'est un lieu
de liberté alors il est évident qu'on a
un petit peu le poids de l'histoire dans
les épaules mais je suis heureux de
pouvoir dire à un ami on pourrait
presque dire puisque il a quand même
fait du séminaire donc il peut dans la
boutique qu' il est petit peut-être
alors à ce qu'il a envie d'être dehors
mais qu'il est aussi deux dents parce
que on est les frontières rôle qu'il
jamais vraiment où quitte jamais
vraiment l'aider bah c'est pas quelque
chose qui est voilà totalement opaque
il est évident que celui qui veut sortir
de l'église sort de l'église et il est
en paix car loin on rappelle pourquoi ce
débat est sur la table aujourd'hui c'est
que ça a été relancé par l'église
catholique allemande cette semaine
puisque voilà il ya eu beaucoup
d'agressions sexuelles par des membres
du clergé qui ont eu lieu et le célibat
des prêtres seraient selon eux la cause
indirecte de ses actes vous vous êtes la
seule à être pour christine kelly
pourquoi pourquoi je suis pour
parce que je ne vois pas pourquoi les
textes on interpréterait la bible au gré
des crises d'engagement il ya une crise
d'engagement des mères est membre des
mères en france il ya une crise dans
gages
des pompiers il ya une crise d'image moi
même des ministres une crise
d'engagement des prêtres et du coup on
dit et on va ouvrir à cause de la crise
d'engagement on va ouvrir les mariages
pourquoi interpréter la bible au gré de
la mode
je suis contre alors attention par
exemple moi je termine juste je parle
des on parle des prêtres qui s'est basé
quand même sur la bible et sur la
religion catholique la bible et les
pasteurs qui se marient je suis pour à
partir de ce moment là si on commence à
interpréter la bible en fonction des
modes
ah oui ben faut ouvrir à la pma pour
tous oui faut ouvrir la possibilité pour
les femmes aussi de prêcher il y en a
beaucoup qui hochent la tête là qui sont
pas d'accord car elle verrait bien dans
un an je ne pense pas que le sujet se
soit créé un engagement d'abord je veux
moi salué le discours de alexis du père
alexis discours de tolérance et
gendarmes et reconnu c'est un discours
de tolérance mutuelle son discours qui
est basée sur le respect de l amour mais
je trouve que c'est un message qui est
plutôt intéressant après j'aimerais vous
dire alexis là où je ne comprends pas ce
célibat de mon point de vue mais c'est
ma part de vérité il est contre nature
et je crois qu'il est un peu hypocrite
il était pourri parce que quelque part
vous vous vous refusez l'idée qu'on
puisse être un bon prêtre bien servir
l'église tout en étant un bon père de
famille ou amoureux d'une femme
je trouve que c'est au contraire puisque
dans l'église catholique il y à des
prêtres mariés hommes d'allegri l'église
catholique il y a des préparer donc
c'est une contre-vérité mais je savais
de dire c'est contre vous vous êtes mal
des voeux de chasteté n'est pas
hypocrite alors ça ça me concerne moi
personnellement le mien vous pouvez le
traité d'hypocrite
vous pouvez qualman alors également le
célibat c'est comme la sexualité de
chacun c'est une affaire personnelle
c'est une affaire intime n'est pas
d'être indépendant
est ce que c'est pour ça que le célibat
des prêtres n'est pas une obligation 10
ecclésiale dans la bible comme ça bien
été dit c'est un choix historique qu'on
peut tout à fait remettre en cause et
dès que je serai pape je réfléchirai
sérieusement à cette chose
mais si on est pas mais vous n'êtes plus
ouvert juste un tournoi pas une foire
cyril aujourd'hui yoplait
oui à côté de moi dans la peau menant au
direct j'espère il ya un moyen de voter
un truc sur twitter sur coutras
christine que ça n'a rien à voir avec la
bible parce qu'il a fallu milan à
l'église pour imposer le célibat ça a
beaucoup varié la doctrine
la première chose ensuite moi j'ai
toujours été contre le célibat des
prêtres est en effet l'accumulation des
scandales sexuels a achevé de me
convaincre moi je suis d'une famille qui
est partagé entre catholiques et
orthodoxes les traîtres en stand up si
son l'époque peuvent se marier et
l'église orthodoxe n'est absolument pas
touché par cette vague de scandales donc
j'en déduis qu'il ya quand même un
rapport de cause à effet et ensuite il
ya deux autres choses que j'ajouterai il
faut en sortir avec une forme
d'hypocrisie c'est à dire les couples
clandestins mais ils sont assez nombreux
et aussi le fait je regrette alain sur
les gouvernants que les ecclésiastiques
raconte beaucoup les bordels et les
maisons closes
oui et puis surtout on a appris on a un
peu évoqué le sujet il faut en finir
avec cette répression de la chaire que
fait l'église catholique parce qu'en
effet je reprends le mode mon camarade
c'est contre nature est fait de vouloir
réprimer les élans de la chair je pense
que ça ne mène à rien etc d'églises
catholiques qui devait s'envoler
on va voir votre réponse d'un instant
père vers le coup juste agathe qui lève
la main depuis tout à l'heure à y agir a
dit notion là où votre discours très
beau demeurant moi je le trouve bien
hypocrite ou utopiste je ne sais pas
parce que vous vous revendiquez l'église
comme une terre d'ouverture comme un
lieu d'ouverture où tout le monde
peuvent être comme ils le souhaitent
venir entrée sortie heureuse pour
reprendre vos termes sur une boîte de
nuit et ben vraisemblablement 6 sauf que
monsieur ici présent ce sens est
tellement en ce sens tellement coincé à
la société tellement à l'e3 se sont
tellement pris dans un dilemme moral
terrible qu'il a pensé au pire
donc je ne pense pas que ce que l'église
que vous revendiquez soit les légumes
alors prince l attention attention là là
parce que l'ail est généralisée lui il
est peut-être tombé
voilà sur les mauvaises personnes s'ils
étaient tombés sur vous le texte se
seraient passées autrement et que la
mutation se serait fait beaucoup plus
facilement donc voilà il faut pas faire
des généralités oui la mer dom après cet
homme comme suit aussi gens ne regardent
alors sur tous les sujets ont fait sa
maman géraldine qu'on abandonne après
berne area prévert en dhr et vercorin
monsieur même si vous êtes marié moi
j'adorerais que vous soyez mon prêtre je
pense que le rabbin et marié ça se passe
très bien le pasteur et marié ça se
passe très bien l'imam est marié et ça
se passe très bien
oui bah gâteau pouvait pas varié ça se
passe très mal après une avancée une
avancée vers vers la modernité et je
pense que ça pourrait aussi éviter aussi
les problèmes de vocations aujourd'hui
dans l'église catholique alors sur de
très très bonnes idées et je les garde
je les écoute et je vais la prendre la
parole j'ai fait une remarque à faire
c'est que l'église elle a un
fonctionnement ultra jupitérien s'il ya
des fonctionnements jupitérien en france
si vous étes trés bas à côté du pape qui
est tous là haut et les voies qui
peuvent être portés ici d'ouverture de
certains noms mais à la journée 8 il ya
un synode des jeunes réparable et non
alors il ya une assemblée des jeunes du
monde entier à rome en ce moment de tous
les pays du monde à rome avec le pape et
le pape écoute des jeunes qui viennent
du monde entier qui représente leur
église et je suis d'accord que nous ne
rions pas toujours par notre gentillesse
et je le demande humblement pardon parce
que très bien ça n'empêche que le
célibat que je vis est une expérience
personnelle que vous pouvez être contre
mon expérience personnelle alexis juste
voulait dire un truc et quand il veut
parler c'est a priori un rack tueur est
gentil
l'un des méchants aussi mais c'était une
question au départ d'amour et c'était de
savoir comment est ce que vous alliez
faire pour l'accepter malgré que vous
est déçu il fallait avoir l'amour
cette force d'amour nécessaire de
l'accepter avec ce qui vous qu'il a
faits qui pour certains est bon comme il
est mal bien sûr qu alors maintenant
bien sûr c'est le ballon prenez-le
maintenant la question naïve a pas le
moindre effort c'est important alors on
respecte l'âme au monsieur bercoff renom
petits mots je suis très frappé tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil tout le monde ici sait mais
pourquoi c'est contre nature
enfin il ya des gens qui ont fait voeu
de chasteté dieu sait si je suis pas
catholique c'est pas bon bon à rappeler
à votre cas personnel
oui mais je veux dire que c'est
hallucinant il y a des gens qui ont fait
voeu de chasteté et nomme aussi ça
s'empêche d'ailleurs une femme aussi et
je veux dire yelle l'exercice de volonté
pour qu'on dit tout de suite à la la
c'est contre nature j'ai pas bien mais
ce n'est pas vrai toute l'église n'est
pas obsédé sexuel au karité ne me dis
pas que tu te l'elysée bernard et
beaucoup mais il ya dans toutes les
religions il ya des images et la db je
fais c'est pour ça c'est pour cette
région connue pour repas c'est aussi
savait que ce mariage ou pas le mariage
qui change c'est ça que je veux dire et
ce à toutes les religions vous avez des
gens qui sont des tordus et ce n'est pas
le célibat qui fait le jeu n'est pas
vrai est-ce que de pédophilie quand même
là je veux je veux pas faire de lien
direct
reste qu'il vaut mieux pas non mais je
suis anti fille camille sée fossé
j'ai même rencontré sur paul arrivé je
veux pas faire la billetterie est une
maladie très grave
d'accord ce qui est grave dans l'église
c'est pas qu'ils aient quelques prêtres
pédophiles de ce qui est très grave mais
il y en a partout dans tous les corps
d'état de mes déchets c'est grave c'est
que l'institution puisse les couvrir et
ça ces derniers d'accord messager et moi
après vivre le célibat rond pédophile
c'est une ânerie absolument non mais
il ya quand même pas d'aller à l'arrière
mais après après je vous donne la parole
à adriano pas d'automaticité ne ne
caricature est pas notre propos quand je
disais que j'étais content ici bas je ne
suis pas contre le vôtre à peu ce qu'on
trouve en général quand je dis qu'il
peut y avoir un lien
je ne dis pas qu'il est automatique je
dis simplement que s'il ya des pulsions
pour des gens qui se force vers le
célibat alors qu'ils ne pourrez assouvir
ses pulsions d'une autre manière si
l'église ne l'autorisé donc peut-être
qu'ils effectuent main qu'on aurait
moins de des rires vous étiez tous des
anciens
c'est un ancien mongrain qui sait de
quoi il parle les rigoles débat ouvert
non mais un ancien curé qui dit ce
célibat forcé voilà la boutique nature
equilis acceptant des accusés pour rien
je lui dis je pense qu' il existe les
statistiques qui avait une dizaine
d'années en arrière et je pense que ça
va plutôt un d'en savoir qui n'a
toujours de plus en plus des actes de
pédophilie chez les prêtres et c'est à
dire de plus en plus montré que si c'est
à dire que si sur 1000 milles port y en
a qui se jettent sur les petits cochons
il y en aura moins d'actes en tout que
dans tout le reste de la france parce
qu'il y en a dix mille ou cent mille de
porc ou mais oui il ya peut-être moins
d'actes dans l'église mais que peut-être
il y en a plus et de ruissellement river
school à ce qu'on signale ce soir et est
ce que vient de dire monsieur c'est
qu'ils disaient c'est vrai que ça
pouvait voilà exactement
non mais c'est vrai que il disait que
nous c'est bien sûr c'est très
dérangeant mais c'est vrai qu'il y en a
partout mais le problème qu'il ya c'est
que ce soit maquillés par l'église et
que voilà c'est sur la voilà qu'on
dénonce aujourd'hui c'est à boursies
c'est quelque chose qui est très
importante c'est que tout ce qui rentre
au séminaire pour être prêtre sans
choisir le célibat font une erreur et
que malheureusement on les conduit à
cette erreur parce que c'est pas un vrai
engagement des diables par des hommes
mariés coordonne qu'ils baptisent qui
marie qui annonce la parole ils sont
mariés j'en avais dans ma paroisse on
était trois mille à peu près dans ma
communauté à côté de la tour
montparnasse
on n'était que quatre prêtres sur les
3000 mais il y avait deux diacres qui
était mariée qui célébrait titré chez
canon c'est la parole tous ces
catholiques et tous les membres de ma
famille qui sont marrés
le seul à avoir fait ce choix là ils
sont catholiques ils sont mariés ils
vivent l'amour et sont très heureux
alors le fait que je choisisse d'être
célibataire est un choix perdre 7 euros
ce jeudi au cours d'un engagement est
heureuse d'aller vous êtes heureux d'un
très malheureux c'est horrible nous
avons des retraites
franchement vous avez l'air très heureux
non en tout cas je je veux qu'on montre
que les perversions elles viennent d'un
célibat mal choisi d'accord faut aider
les gens à choisir leur fiche pour vous
poser une question ne faut pas laisser
se révèle marié c'est les gens se
marient question car il est juché sur
une question directe entre vous n'avez
jamais eu une attirance pour une femme
depuis que vous êtes au près depuis que
j'ai l'âge de 6 ans je suis attiré par
les femmes et je le suis encore plus
aujourd'hui
non bien sûr oui j'ai fait le tour de
toutes les couleurs sur l'un des
avancées réelles de la volonté dont vous
mettez en a qualifié donc voulu tu
aimais voulu tester vous mais c'est bien
car ils se répondent chez lui et oui
ça veut dire que vous vous lister tous
les jours comment vous luttez tous les
jours tous les jours je me réjouis je me
réjouis de voir toutes les femmes qui
sont là que je trouve charmante away et
que parce que j'en ai j'en ai pas il
faut pas qu'il fasse il la tentation
mais bon